is it true that when you first came to
La you would sleep in open houses like
open houses well you know what you can't
do that anymore because I don't think
has an alarm system yes but when I first
came to La I first thing I did was buy a
car it's either a par a car or a place
to live well you need a car you're in
L.A so I would just sleep in my car and
when I would go to open houses that I
open Sunday from noon to four
so I get there at 3 30 look around the
house okay thank you realtor thank you
I'd slammed the front door then I go
hide in the closet you know I'd stand
there another half hour they hear the
realtor lock up and I would live in the
house for three or four days that's
crazy and I never I never I never broke
anything I always made the bad dog and I
did that a bunch of times and then I was
standing at a beautiful house on
Coldwater Canyon I later found out was
owned by one of the Beach Boys you know
so so I'm sleeping I hear the real thing
now in here here's a lovely room
[Laughter]
sorry excuse me let me get out of here
please yes but actually it was a great
place you saved a fortune and rent and
you didn't
and I lived in beautiful I think it's
called squatting yeah yeah yeah I could
say that yeah I think you do say that
yeah
that's something I had to live in my car
for a few days when I lived here because
my place burned down that's
uncomfortable it is it is yeah even in
the recline position I had a 55 Buick
which is it's enormous oh oh yeah you
could seat six for dinner in this car
okay you could lay out yeah in fact it
didn't have a radio it had live ax
that's how big it was it was a live
bands yes
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]